At Genii Games, what
we do is develop
African coach or
teaching apps for kids.
What I've had to
do in terms of this
is go back to even my
own secondary school
to pick out my teachers.
I mean, the ones who
taught me [INAUDIBLE],
taught me [INAUDIBLE] back then.
So I had to work with
these different people.
What they've done
is they've helped me
in terms of structuring
this content.
And to date, what I have with
them is a good relationship
that ensures that I
can go back to them
for vetting of this
content or even updating
of the present ones we have.
Interestingly, times I've spent
with customers, specifically,
it's been-- because
we build mechanisms
into our applications that
allow for these customers
to reach out to us with feedback
and things like that to better
our products going forward.
I mean, I've had
situations where
we go from just them
sending feedback
to connecting via Skype.
And most of these people,
the interesting thing
is I've never met them.
And it's always interesting
when we're Skyping
and there's, oh, we love this.
Or they're sending
videos of their kids
using these applications.
My team, we have a mantra
which we call push,
and it's to continue pushing
until something happens.
So that's how we keep
living every day.